geoffery going back to before you were a
Hollywood screenwriter what made you
think you could tell stories on a
Hollywood level what gave you that
confidence or that feeling that
intuition that you know what this is
something I think I can do um I think
it's the ignorance of the young you know
I talked to a friend of mine once it was
probably a couple years ago and I was
home and she said when I was like 8 or 9
she asked me what I wanted to do when I
grew up and I said I wanted to be a
movie star so I kind of always knew I
wanted to work in film I was growing up
thought I wanted to be an actor and I
went to New York to study acting
actually at the beginning of my career
and that didn't pan out really because
non-traditional casting wasn't a thing
back in the early 90s and they cancelled
the Cosby Show so then non-traditional
casting that was like your only place so
then English was my second favorite
subject and I'd been writing you know
from the time I was young I just always
would write stories and my English
teachers kind of my biggest inspirations
as far as school goes so I was like well
just write stuff to be in so that's kind
of why I said wait into writing but you
just when you're younger you don't think
of you know Hollywood does seem like
this far away magical place in a way but
you also are very naive about how the
movie business is so you think oh you
just you write something and somebody
likes it in and they go out and pick up
a camera they make it and then it comes
out in the theater and that's kind of
when you're younger that's kind of all
you could think about you don't know
exact
convoluted twisted process of
screenwriting and you know getting
something from page to screen when
you're young so you're kind of in that
magical like illusion language I can do
it you know
so yeah that's again the writing wasn't
always my wasn't my first goal but but
movement working in movies has always
been pretty much just what I want to do
my whole life so that's kind of my only
get career gameplan boy how small was
the town that you grew up in um we had
like that I think 100 students in her
graduating class I almost feel like I
should google that I should know that it
was a very small town it took us it
wasn't for like a 40 minute bus ride to
get to school every day oh wow
so we were like the last stop out there
down the hills so it was Eastern
Kentucky so it was very small town they
didn't have a theatre program like my
English teacher when I was a sophomore I
talked her into creating a theater
program for like
once the the one year and then it kind
of died out after that year but yeah I
was I was pretty determined you know
it's it's very interesting when you're
young and you're driven because you
that's one of the things you try to tell
people to hold on to because you get a
little older you know that the drive
doesn't necessarily go away but it's you
know the realities of the business and
the distractions can kind of get your
way so when you're young you just have
that that boundless like energy and
faith and optimism and you know you try
to hold on to that magic you know even
when you start getting into the business
side of things right because as you get
older you kind of talk yourself out of
it knowing all the things that can go
wrong right and it's almost a shame I
mean there's that I just like at this
protective part that is there for that
reason but then yeah but you know parent
you know and it's nobody encourages a
career in the arts like if you tell
anybody we know you want to be an actor
or a writer or they're always saying
well you know that's great what are you
gonna do for a real job like that's
pretty much the reaction my mom did not
know that I majored in theater in
college till after I was in college like
I tell her I was majoring in in math and
she got so mad she found out I made
majored in theater because I could never
gonna be able to make a living doing
that and you know so there was a reality
but for me like again I just never had a
back-up plan so you know I think you
know luckily I was good in English and
writing was was another passion of mine
so I found a way to stay in the business
and not give up when the act you didn't
kind of pan out as soon as I had hoped
it would so but yeah people like well
usually tell anybody he says they want
to be in the film business or any kind
of art they're like oh that'll be a good
hobby what are you gonna do for a real
job and so that's kind of just part of
our society we don't really value I
think in in this country I think in
other countries they do value their arts
more than we do here but usually arts
programs are the first things to get cut
in schools you know it's like sports
number one then science and math and
stuff and then the arts are usually kind
of down here as far as his priorities go
which is it which is interest because I
think the arts are probably wanted to
we're helpful just to help you as an
even being to kind of grow and like
expand your horizons open your mind and
just you know also get in touch with
your emotions a lot of stuff that a lot
of the
other fields don't really emphasize or
help you do I think the arts that's why
a lot of people love the arts but um it
is you know that's something I think we
have to start valuing a lot more in our
country it's funny you mentioned sports
because I think I heard you say in
another interview and I laughed out loud
when I heard it that people that are
into horror probably weren't people that
were playing sports yeah yeah and they
weren't the cheerleaders and they
weren't the job yeah I am I thought that
was great because it's true you develop
this this interesting imagination that
when you're in that sort of herd
mentality trying to be popular all that
probably isn't isn't going through your
mind so you talk about that and there's
a lot to I mean you know if you're an
athlete too like that's your whole life
like you're always practicing you're
always you know when you're not at
school practicing you're practicing at
home you're watching what you eat you're
working out you're so that's your whole
life so you don't yeah I think you know
most of the people that I know who are
artists you know they smell start time
at home like you know watching movies or
reading comic books or you know doing
kind of nerdy geeky things like just you
know it you know really playing in their
imagination or with their imagination
and I think that's a kind of a common
thing you find you'll find with artists
is you know a lot of artists will you
know didn't have like a big clique that
they hung out with or weren't really you
know super popular and some of them were
but but again it is you know especially
in high school it's because I know it's
like schools like a machine you know you
have so it's very important obviously
get an education when you have so many
kids going through every year that you
don't have time to like everybody's got
their own individual personalities and
you can't really get to know people so
you gotta have to shove them in boxes to
like you know just to process people
it's a you know it's a weird thing that
I've noticed as we grow up because
people still try to generalize you know
in a way and so that's even when I talk
when I Joe it's not even you have a lot
about like you know the jocks and the
cheerleaders aren't the ones that were
home watching a lot of horror movies
it's also because they were out
practicing and doing sure their thing
but it's into how we still kind of keep
those boxes as we get older and you know
I sound a little bulky hippie right now
but I found it I thought it was funny
because there's a lot of truth to it so
you know
you